und jetzt sehen wir natürlich hier schon
das worauf ich schon mehrfach
hingewiesen habe nämlich markus söder
den ministerpräsidenten aus bayern und
cdu-vorsitzenden an der seite von
annegret kramp karrenbauer mit einer
schmissigen musik hier
der einzug seitdem diese beiden ihren
beiden parteien vor stehen erinnert sich
mal anderthalb jahre zurück
läuft es zwischen cdu csu wieder
glänzend die hacke reihen der beiden
alten vorsitzenden sind vergangenheit
und das ist der union sicherlich auch zu
wünschen dass das in zukunft so bleibt
denn das war ja eine zeit lang die
opposition innerhalb der
schwesterparteien cdu und csu die beiden
auch mitbekommen ist und das hat markus
söder und annegret kramp karrenbauer im
letzten jahr gleich mal abgestellt
nachdem die gewählt worden ist als
cdu-vorsitzende also die beiden
harmonisieren zumindest was man
öffentlich so sehen kann und auch in den
äußerungen ganz gut miteinander und
markus söder
als csu chef kommt selbstverständlich
hier auf einladung von annegret kramp
karrenbauer um zu reden und sie war ja
kurzen beinen csu parteitag auch in
bayern als rednerin das war ja auch
nicht immer so zwischen den alten
vorsitzenden aber das wollen wir jetzt
mal vergessen das ist die vergangenheit
die zukunft marschiert hier
annegret kramp karrenbauer die cdu
vorsitzende mit markus söder der
natürlich artig die bundeskanzlerin
begrüßt völlig klar und der hier gleich
als gastredner das wort liebe
freundinnen und freunde lieber markus
herzlich willkommen herzlich willkommen
bei freunden herzlich willkommen bei der
großen cdu csu familie herzlich
willkommen dem vorsitzenden der csu hier
bei uns auf unserem bundesparteitag in
leipzig
[Applaus]
wenn wir glaube ich gemeinsam an das
letzte jahr zurück denken da gab es
treffen zwischen cdu und csu
die waren nicht ganz so fröhlich nicht
ganz so entspannt
das waren wirklich dramatische momente
auch für unsere unions familie
das haben wir überwunden und das hat
auch ganz viel mit dir zu tun
dafür möchte ich mich persönlich aber
auch im namen von uns allen ganz
herzlich bedanken und wir freuen uns
jetzt auf das was du uns zu sagen hast
hatte gekommen
[Musik]
damen und herren liebe freunde wir
annegret liebe frau bundeskanzlerin
herzlich danken dank erstmal für den
freundlichen empfang
ich weiß es noch genau mein erster
parteitag als generalsekretär war auch
hier ein leipzig im jahr 2003 das war
die phase wo ist eine reihe von
faszinierenden beschlüssen gab und damit
weiß ich noch es war auch so ein moment
wo cdu/csu und nicht ganz einig waren
es war nicht schwierige stimmung kann
ich mich erinnern edmund stoiber war
nicht so richtig gut gelaunt macht den
parteitag und mich als generalsekretär
versuchte zu erklären warum es so ist
wie das halt so in der arbeitsverteilung
ist ja vorsitzende macht das gut und die
generalsekretäre auch
und ich freue mich sehr dass jetzt nach
so vielen jahren nicht wieder da sein
kann bei ihnen bei euch und ich muss
ihnen eigentlich sagen was mich
besonders freut
was hat es im vorfeld nicht alles für
berichten hoffnungen gegeben nicht nur
wohlmeinende politischer kräfte auch
mancher publizistischen dass dieser
parteitag ein scherbengericht werden
würde dass dieser parteitag ein
schlechtes signal werden würde das
endlich klar wäre dass die union immer
regierungsfähig ist ich möchte euch eins
sagen danke für die begrüßung aber auch
vor allen dingen dankeschön
ihr habt bislang an den tollen parteitag
gemacht sie haben all diejenigen
widerlegt die cdu ist die stärkste
politische kraft herzliches dankeschön
dafür seien gut ist ein wichtiges signal
deutschland braucht uns deutschland
braucht eine starke union
die menschen erwarten sich dass auch und
wir können auch gerade eine woche nach
einem parteitag der grünen in der liebe
freundinnen freunde ja vor allem
versucht wurde eine harmonische show zu
zeigen wäre es ein schlechtes zeichen
gewesen wenn es uns gemeinschaftlich als
union nicht gelingt etwas dagegen zu
halten ja sogar voranzugehen
wir als csu sind die kleine schwester
des steht fest wir können nichts
bestimmen aber ohne uns wäre es auch
langweilig jetzt gebe ich zu wir haben
den familienstatus immer wieder mal über
all die jahrzehnte starke
herausgefordert in den 70er jahren gab
es mal
da wollten uns so für ein zwei tage
trennen ja sind dann aber doch wieder
zusammen gekommen und wir haben die
jahre 2015 bis 2018 keine leichten jahre
gehabt immer wieder zwischen cdu/csu und
jetzt unabhängig davon wer glaubt immer
recht zu haben es war am ende weder für
uns ich glaube auch nicht für euch und
vor allen dingen nicht für unsere
anhänger den anhänger in ganz
deutschland ein gutes signal wenn sich
schwestern dauerhaft streiten ich kann
nur eines sagen was was mich betrifft ja
was mich betrifft ich habe letztes jahr
den wahlkampf erlebt auch in bayern der
war wirklich nicht einfach
da hatten auch viele gehofft es endet
eine historische phase bei uns im
freistaat und ich habe eines gespürt
tief dass wenn wir uns schon nicht einig
sind wer soll sich dann einig sein
wenn wir nicht in der lage sind
gemeinschaftlich zu arbeiten
wie sollen dann die menschen vertrauen
haben in diese große politische familie
und deswegen ist mein versprechen und
der dank an die sich annegret mein
versprechen dass wir so was wie letztes
jahr
nie wieder machen wir wollen zwar nicht
funktionieren aber wir werden so eng
zusammenarbeiten liebe freunde und
deswegen danke an dich annegret wir
haben es jetzt gut aufs gleis gebracht
wir sind eine familie wir sind nur
gemeinsam stark und es sollen auch
zeigen liebe freunde
es ist auch wichtig es ist auch wichtig
den menschen draußen zu vermitteln dass
wir natürlich diese geschlossenheit auch
brauchen und zwar sowohl im blick nach
vorne als auch im blick zurück liebe
freunde die kunst und aufgabe die wir
doch es gemeinschaftlich haben die wir
alle spüren ist neues einzuläuten und
vorzubereiten und mit vergangenen aber
auch zu versöhnen
jetzt weiß ich auch dass wir in den
letzten 14 jahren
manches kann man noch besser machen aber
wir haben doch gemeinschaftlich großes
geleistet wir haben unglaubliche krisen
finanzkrise euro krise gemeistert wo in
deutschland jeder angst hatte um sein
erspartes wo europa am kippen war da war
es der deutsche stabilitäts weckte am
ende zu einem erfolg geführt hat und
liebe freunde
wer vier wahlen hintereinander gewinnt
der kann es nicht so schlecht gemacht
haben und drum lasst uns immer neues
denken aber stolz darauf sein was wir in
den letzten jahren für deutschland
gemeinschaft mit geleistet haben das ist
doch ein großer erfolg an dem wir uns
freuen sollen
[Applaus]
und dieses anlauf ist ja wie im privaten
ja parteien die mit sich selber nicht
glücklich sind wie die spd an der spd
kann man ja die dauer depression gerade
zu spüren ja egal was denen gelingt es
gibt immer irgend jemand der sagt es
reicht mir das ist zu wenig und dann
entstehen bilder und gesichter liebe
freunde die im besten fall traurig und
einsam wirken lädt man jemand zu sich
privat nach hause ein
von dem man weiß dass er den ganzen
abend jammert
[Applaus]
und wenn wir was erleben können was die
grünen im moment ich komme gleich an zu
denen was sie vielleicht besser machen
ist die verbreiten eine stimmung eine
eine harmonie eine freude dass man gar
nicht dass man glaubt daher mit denen
könnte man vielleicht doch irgendwie die
zukunft praktisch einmal eines wir haben
eine solche substanz dass wir wirklich
optimistisch in die zukunft schauen
können
nur wer optimismus zeigt nur wer lust an
neuen zeigt nur wer bereit ist
verantwortung zu übernehmen und von dem
man auch spürt dass er sich traut
herausforderung anzugehen der über die
menschen begeistern ich möchte das wenn
die bürger und bürger in deutschland
entscheiden wen sie am liebsten ihr
wohnzimmer einladen dass die erste
adresse cdu/csu ich liebe freunde und
nicht die anderen
sie können gerne draußen bleiben
ist es jetzt nur wichtig damit man
gewählt werden
na ja auch schon nicht schlecht aber das
ist für die bürgerinnen und bürger nicht
das entscheidende für die bürger bürgers
entscheiden was in den nächsten zeiten
in den unsicheren zeiten so passiert
braucht es dazu uns ja liebe freunde
wen sonst ihr habt es ja die letzten
eineinhalb tage schon sehr ausführlich
beraten konnte gleich noch stärker die
welt ändert sich fundamental alte
freunde machen es einem nicht leicht
wenn ich an washington denke neue
partner sind auch nicht einfach weil es
bleibt in dieser welt auch wenn unser
seite großes misstrauen gegen vieles was
ich da gibt muss euch sagen ich habe
großes verständnis für einen antrag
beispielsweise zu hause
aber wisst ihr was mich am meisten an
dieser debatte eigentlich ärgert dass
wir in deutschland nur darüber reden ob
wir vielleicht ein chinesisches oder ein
amerikanisches unternehmen damit
betrauen und überhaupt nicht mehr
reflektieren das in früheren zeiten man
in china ein deutsches system genommen
hätte und wir heute gar nicht in der
lage sind entsprechend stark zu sein das
ist doch die frage mit der wir uns
stärker auseinandersetzen müssen in der
zukunft
und es ist ja nicht nur international so
natürlich dem auch der demokratische
boden in deutschland betrifft ja etwas
das spüren wir werden uns einige wahlen
denn wir einige erfolge erzielen könnte
was mich sehr freut in sachsen aber
insgesamt doch belastet waren euch das
was afd sich so dargestellt hat ich sage
euch aber auch wir sind jetzt in der
großen koalition die spd ist derzeit
partner aber es immer mal ganz ehrlich
wahrscheinlich nicht der gegner der
feind ist sich bewusst ist für mich die
afg eindeutig
und ja oft dass sie es behaupten desto
weniger wird es war die a fds alles aber
sie ist keine bürgerliche partei liebe
freundin gar nicht ist keine bürgerliche
partei
bürgerliche parteien hetzen nicht
bürgerliche parteien spalten nicht
bürgerliche parteien stellen die
geschichte nicht in frage
bürgerliche parteien stehen im
bayerischen landtag auf wenn man ein
totengedenken macht sorgen ehren des
ermordeten hessischen
regierungspräsidenten und bleiben
einfach sitzen und machen blöde witze
drüber
bürgerliche parteien machen keine tweets
über allem sagen naja ging doch nur eine
angeschossene tür und bei bürgerlicher
parteien gebe es über eines kein zweifel
wenn afd abgründe heute befragt werden
liebe freundin freunde ob sie textlich
an den unterschied erkennen könnten
jüngsten der fernsehsendung zwischen den
schriften von herrn röcke und aus mein
kampf als die abgründe können sich nicht
sicher sein was der unterschied ist
woran könnte das liegen weil es
vielleicht gar keinen richtigen
unterschied gibt meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren das ist doch der wahre
grund
[Applaus]
während in bayern auch darüber
nachgedacht und sind ja auch ganz
ehrlich
gerade das letzte jahr an ein teil des
streits angela maier aus dieser
unsicherheit geschuldet was ist der
richtige weg da auch wie muss man sich
verhalten ich kann euch nur sagen was
die erfahrung des letzten jahres es
klappt nicht
auch durch scharfer rhetorik dort zu
überholen etwas zurück zu gewinnen ohne
gleichzeitig tief in der bürgerlichen
mitte erhebliche substanzverluste zu
haben und deswegen
[Applaus]
lasst uns da auch nicht herumspielen mit
dem thema lasst uns dann den geheimen
zirkeln darüber nachdenken ob übrigen
wie er seine gelegenheit gebe unter
welchen umständen arithmetisch
vielleicht und vielleicht sind alle da
nicht so schlimm
die funktionäre der afd die immer
stärker werden
die haben ein anderes weltbild die
wollen nicht zurück in die 70er liebe
freunde die wollen zurück in die 30er
und deswegen ist die afd
die afc ist nicht irgendwie eine
konservativere union sondern sie ist die
eigentliche neue ware npd und mit
solchen leuten macht man nicht sondern
bekämpft sehen und zwar engagiert und
streitbar liebe freunde
[Applaus]
also
klare linie klare kante fps feind wer
ist jetzt unser haupt herausforderer
eigentlich kann es nur für bayern sagen
und wenn wir die umfragen national sie
zieht man es auch wie gesagt die spd ist
da aber ich muss auch wenn ich das so
sagen darf ihr habt nachher entscheidet
ja noch über heute fragen wir nur eins
sagen wir haben auch am partei darüber
urwahl und sowas geredet ich kann nur
eines sagen so richtig ist der weg der
spd bei so einer frage jetzt nicht gar
ein totales vorbild für uns wenn ich das
sagen aber so richtig
und außerdem würden auch gern noch zu
klein bisschen mitreden als csu ist noch
nicht bei so wäre es jetzt aus meiner
sicht der hauptherausforderungen ganz
ehrlich das sind natürlich die grünen
der wer denn sonst
die grünen sind es da darf man sich
nicht täuschen
keiner weiß was nach wahlen ist und die
demokraten dann zusammenarbeit
organisieren müssen aber vor der wahl
müssen wir uns schon mal überlegen wer
ist denn gesellschaftspolitisch
inhaltlich und personell uns
herausfordern
ich glaube nicht dass das am ende tv
duelle mit sahen wir mal im schlimmsten
fall borjans und es geben wird sondern
wahrscheinlich so wie bei mir daheim war
die hauptherausforderung ein grüner oder
eine grüne kandidatin die wir dann im tv
zu stellen haben darum sage ich euch
schon auch schwarz und grün ist
zumindest bis zur bundestagswahl nicht
die frage sondern schwarz oder grün weil
die frei sein
wir liegen ist die realität und auch das
sage ich es wird am ende so wichtig es
ist darüber nachzudenken wer kanzler
kandidatin oder kandidat werden kann
aber die kernfrage ist nicht nur zu
überlegen wann wir kandidaten aufstellen
sondern entscheidende frage ist wer
steht am ende da denn mir ist egal wer
kandidat war
ich will dass über 20 21 und auch auf
der kanzlerin kann von der union
gestellt werden das ist die
entscheidende frage und nicht von den
grünen liebe freundinnen und freunde
so sehe ich die südschiene gut finde ja
logischerweise ja aber das modell baden
württemberg juniorpartner von den grünen
zu sein ehrlicher weise das macht einem
keine freude beim kollegen strom ist
sieht man es nicht so weil er gut
ausschaut aber ja es liegt an den tollen
land aber es ist nicht unser zug und
klappt es sind uns einig so jetzt die
frage gibt es auch inhaltliche
unterschiede und liebe von natürlich die
grünen machen im moment keine schlechte
figur
aber habt ihr genau analysiert was sie
auf ihrem parteitag eigentlich wirklich
beschlossen haben
das ist kein angebot an an bürgerliche
wähler oder in unsere wähler ist ein
ganz knallhartes programm in richtung
links sowie sie übrigens immer wenn sie
die chance haben zu wählen wenn sie
müssen okay aber wenn sie die chance
haben zu wählen darf sie mal keiner
torchance war doch in bremen auch so da
war doch die optimale situation eine
abgewählte rot grüne regierung alles
kaputt kann man jetzt an ist es
irgendwie siegeslauf dort war und dann
hat man die chance gehabt zu entscheiden
mit einem frischen neuen kandidaten
union oder mit der alten spd weiter und
sie haben sich nicht nur entschieden mit
der alten spd weiter zu machen sie haben
sich noch verstärkt mit der linkspartei
liebe freunde und immer nur eines sagen
wer am ende die linkspartei der union
vorzieht der zeigt ein stück weit sein
wahres gesicht und ich kann nur sagen
das wollen wir nicht liebe freunde das
ist ein unterschied
[Applaus]
wir haben lieber angela liebe annegret
ein klima paket beschlossen es mag das
sein dass des vielen ganz engagierte
noch nicht genug ist international seien
alle chapeau weil die meisten lösen
übrigens ihre klima probleme in europa
mit mehr kernkraft und nicht mit so
einem riesenpaket was wir gemacht haben
und mein eindruck ist übrigens die
mehrzahl der bürgerinnen und bürger
dieses landes wollen was an klimaschutz
tun
sie sind für ökologie natürlich was denn
sonst die welt verändert sich aber sie
möchten kein überzogenes paket was haben
die grünen beschlossen
höhere steuern viermal so viel höhere
preise zwar eine unmengen an verboten
bundesfernstraßen sollen umgebaut und
soll den der uns in liebe freunde sie
der unsinn
sofortiges verbot von ölheizungen wir
machen ja da in unserem klima paket der
übergangsphase aber es gibt wahnsinnig
viele
es gibt wahnsinnig viele regionen in
deutschland wo wenn jetzt eine solche
heizung aus chile
peter altmaier es keinen ersatz gebe was
ist das grüne modell heißt dann dass die
leute frieren in wald gehen und holz
stellen dürfen sie ja auch nicht liebe
freunde weil datenschützer dagegen sind
das ist doch alles ein unsinn ja
und weil wir gerade draußen an kinder
nicht bei einem auto stand war natürlich
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wollen wir elektromobilität wasserstoff
wir wollen wir wollen brennstoffzelle
biokraftstoffe wir haben doch eine idee
wie die zukunft des automobils aussieht
aber das auto ist doch in deutschland
nicht der feind manch einer glaubt ja
das seien es schlimmer sei als ein
atomkraftwerk wenn man sie so reden hört
und es braucht es braucht am ende auch
ein stück weit wieder vernunft wir haben
doch das herz am rechten fleck wir haben
doch die richtige einstellung wir haben
es bewusst sein wer war denn die ersten
umweltpolitiker in deutschland gekommen
daraus unseren reihen weil die bewahrung
der schöpfung ist keine ideologische
sondern eine christliche frage und diese
idee stammt von uns liebe freunde und
nicht von den anderen nicht von den
andern
[Applaus]
und deswegen auch noch mal zum auto ist
doch ein wenn der mast hierher kommt und
sagt er will hier autos bauen
la-ola-wellen alle begeistert ja taumeln
vorfreude
er verspricht er wird arbeitsplätze
machen schauen wir mal ob die
versprechen von herrn macht ihn
interessant und die eigene kraft liegt
in der faszination so warum hab ja da
gab aber während wir gleichzeitig kann
musk loben betreiben wir seit jahren ein
unglaubliches bashing gegen unsere
eigene automobil strukturen ich sage
euch eines kein land der welt würde so
schlecht über die eigene wichtigste
industrie reden wie wir es in
deutschland machen liebe freunde ist
doch absurd
ich glaube nicht dass man mit
philosophie allein millionen
arbeitsplätze in deutschland sichern
kann
herzliche grüße an handhabung und grüne
haben viele kluge leute keine frage
interessante konzepte und wir müssen an
einigen stellen auch sehr genau zuhören
und gut antworten es ist nicht mehr so
wie vor 20 jahren zusammen das geht
alles nicht unter und wir wissen des
lebens klug sein aber an einer stelle
fällt etwas auf was mir manchmal so
anstrengend kommt in der deutschen
politik wird ja übrigens auch gern die
faktenlage verdrängt aber gern der
moralische ansatz bewertet
und da hat man das gefühl in
diskussionen die eigentliche beste moral
die stärkste moral in der politischen
argumentation die selber den grünen
wir hätten ihn nicht nur nach meiner
ansicht muss ich sagen sich das schon
manche der bilder der realität als ich
stelle fest dass die grünen beim ihren
bayerischen landtag ich kann nur von
bayern uns ständig gegen fliegen und
flughäfen reden
aber wer fliegt am meisten liebe freunde
um sich in der welt zu informieren die
grünen die grünen sind für die völlige
freigabe von drogen aber beschließen
jenes mal regelmäßig fleisch muss
verboten gehören liebe freunde
wenn sie dran sind beschließen sie
wälder zu roden wie in nrw in wensin
immer dran sind demonstrieren sie
dagegen sie sie sind für mehr mobilfunk
aber bekämpfen mit jeder
bürgerinitiative vor ort die sie dann
über sms koordinieren jeden ast
[Applaus]
und wenn ich das auch sagen darf ich war
letztes sonntag genannt der
fernsehsender bei anne will und da fand
ich schon einiges bemerkenswert dass wir
in bayern sitzen sehr vernehmbare
energien und uns ist halt einfach die
sonne mehr als der wind so und scheint
halt einfach die sonne so nicht
politischem abermals weise
jetzt kriege ich dann immer schlimm für
uns da und warum macht ihr nicht winde
und abstandsregler peter altmaier wird
geschimpft ja und dann entdeckt das
finde ich bemerkenswert war einer
talkshow des deutschen fernsehens sofort
vermuten ist dass man die grünen mit
einer schwierigen situation konfrontiert
werden dann entdecke ich und wird
genannt dass die grünen in brandenburg
denselben abstand fordern wie peter
altmaier jetzt könnte man sagen das
müssen wir jetzt am peter altmeier
zweifeln das wäre eine variante
ich befürchte es andersrum wisst ihr was
mich echt so stört hier immer das eine
fordern dort was anders tun
ich sage euch eines natürlich haben die
grünen moral
ich glaube die haben zum teil auch mehr
moral als wir die haben nämlich eine
doppelmoral und das sollten wir den
menschen und vom land endlich sagen
liebe freunde wir haben es satt ihn zu
hören
ich wünsche zu lang machen weil ich weiß
ich habe ein grußwort und an diesem
partei denn ist wichtig zu unterscheiden
zwischen grußworte und reden
[Gelächter]
aber aber noch ein ansatz weil wir auch
von unseren wir haben jetzt im letzten
in diesem jahr noch im letzten jahr
schaffen wir es immer neue
herausforderungen anzunehmen und zu
lösen haben es gut gemacht steht
übrigens auch sehr vor dem vorher nach
einspruch habe ich gehört zu der grund
wende weil ich glaube dass das auch zu
uns dazu gehört liebe freunde das wir
soziale verantwortung haben und ich will
es alle der spd überlassen weil ich
finde es gehört auch in dem land dazu
dass wir natürlich leistungsfähigkeit
definieren aber zur leistungsfähigkeit
kommt am ende auch dazu wenn wir
millionen menschen haben ihr leben lang
gearbeitet haben und danach vertraut
haben dass sie am ende dass sie am ende
eine gerechte unterstützung bekommen das
nicht klappt und wir uns dann mühe geben
dies zu erreichen muss ich eigentlich
sagen auch die reihe von vielen anderen
danke das schlägt ja manchmal ins
ordnungspolitische herz dann schon etwas
höher und zwar auch der impuls bei dir
ja wenn wir dann über dinge reden aber
wisst ihr liebe freunde wenn wir am ende
nicht in der lage gewesen werden wegen
100 euro freibetrag eine so wichtige
frage für viele menschen zu entscheiden
dann hat man es auch nicht besser
gemacht als hermann dirigierte regierung
haben an müller in der weimarer zeit die
an kleinen dingen gescheitert ist an
sozialen fragen liebe freunde macht man
keine wahlkämpfe
wir sind eine christlich-demokratische
wir die soziale union und wir waren
immer diejenigen die sozialpolitisch die
menschen zusammengeführt haben und es
sollten ja auch in der zukunft bleiben
liebe freunde
auch das ist ein unterschied zu anderen
wir werden im nächsten jahr was tun
müssen für die konjunktur noch wenn die
spd sagt das spielt keine rolle
das wird so passieren es wird so
passieren bei auto und zulieferer in
geht's los bei anderes auto täuscht man
es nicht konsum überdeckt ist im moment
etwas aber konsum geht immer der
industrie her und deswegen spielt ist
natürlich eine rolle
steuerpolitik positiv zu gestalten
natürlich müssen wir unternehmenssteuern
bremen die langfristige entwicklung des
soli muss man reden
und wenn ich das ehrlich sagen darf ich
erwarte von einem finanzminister in
deutschland den wir in der
zusammenarbeit durchaus schätzen aber
und dem können wir auch sehr werner
parteivorsitzender war einiges muss
schon klar sein
der finanzminister in deutschland muss
sich in erster linie gedanken machen wie
wir die steuern international so
anpassen dass arbeitsplätze gesichert
werden und nicht vereine dafür bestrafen
weil sie traditionsbewusstsein liebe
freunde das ist der falsche schwerpunkt
der falsche ansatz für finanzpolitik in
deutschland
und neben diesem thema müssen wir die
partei der zukunft sein die partei der
zukunft
die forschung ist meiner ansicht nach
die schlüsselfrage für den erfolg
unserer volkswirtschaft und natürlich
ist so dass die anderen mittlerweile
investieren ist unglaublich wie im
fußball
und kommt mir das mal vor wenn ich sehe
was wir haben spitzenforscher im bereich
künstler und ergänzt die kriegen e-mails
aus china mit geldangeboten konzessions
e mails einfach so massen emails und
dass die amerikaner attraktiv sind
wissen wir auch also wird es nicht
reichen nur zusammen sind schon ganz gut
und deutsche forschungs idee wir müssen
schwerpunkte prioritäten setzen wir
haben es bei uns im freistaat eine
hightech agenda gemacht mit 2 milliarden
euro nur für ein land allein 100
lehrstühle für k s ist einiges mehr als
unser größter wettbewerber baden
württemberg macht die schon ausgelobt
haben mit 20
angela merkel sagte mir ungefähr 100
etwas über 100 werden in deutschland
gefördert und angela sagte dann auch
noch sie haben die regierungserklärung
gelesen und hat mich gelockt dafür und
ihr wisst wenn die bundeskanzlerin
bayern not dann nur weil es nicht anders
geht
ja
[Applaus]
mahlzeit stimmt ja und
aber warum er wenig dass ich sage das
war für mich sehr wenn ich habe für
diese regierung schon für das konzept
das jetzt machen könnten noch viel
anders dazu kriegen die internationale
resonanz und manchmal musst du dich dann
in debatten gar noch von der linken
seite rechtfertigen dürfe ich habe zum
beispiel ein engagiertes
raumfahrtprogramm gemacht was haben sie
da gelästert jaja der markus söder will
zum mond ja ich meine ich wusste schon
wenig dorthin schickte erst wirklich das
problem aber aber arbeit damit seine
raumfahrt ich beende ist deswegen eine
raumfahrt fakultät gegründet eine neue
junge studentinnen und studenten mit
einer glühenden begeisterung für das
thema wenn bei dem thema hyper loop eine
neue form der transport möglichkeit
haben wir das studenten themen an der
technischen münchen die zum vierten mal
in folge die hoch dotierten preise von
herrn musk international gewinnen
jetzt will man eigentlich sagen wir
reden in deutschland über alle möglichen
helden und zeichnen sie aus
dabei haben wir junge forscherinnen und
forscher die international erfolgreich
sind und über technologie leisten man
irgendwie so allgemein länger ich sage
euch ein ist das sind unsere botschafter
der zukunft das sind diejenigen die wir
brauchen für ein starkes land und wir
als union müssen diesen jungen menschen
und dieser jugend die bereit ist auch
die zukunft anzupacken dienen müssen wir
möglichkeiten weg eröffnen
die sollen bayern sein team das ist die
zukunft unseres landes liebe freunde
mehr als manche andere demonstration wie
wir leben
so also ich finde nicht dass unser akku
leer ist also meiner sowieso nicht aber
unsere auch nicht ich finde er lädt sich
auch ständig neu du kannst sonne planen
welche herausforderungen immer kommt
politik ist ja zwei s2 leiten muss schon
ein kurs setzen ruster in der lage sein
auf das was da kommt an internationalen
veränderungen zu reagieren
die welt hat sich dramatisch
weiterentwickelt hätte ich vor vielen
jahren so nie gesehen
je mehr verantwortlich in meiner partei
und in meinem land habe desto mehr sehe
ich was ich da international tut
deutscher provinzialismus in der
hoffnung des zieht an uns vorbei war
schon immer gefährlich liebevolle nun
ist es auch ob technologie oder anecke
den dem schwierigen amt muss ganz
ehrlich sagen liebe freundin freunde
wenn ihn zu substanziellen fragen wie
der sicherheit deutschlands
das einzige argument in der
öffentlichkeit ist ob man eine halbe
stunde früher oder später informiert
würde dann kann ich sagen hätte
deutschland keine sorgen
die angeht macht einen tollen job als
verteidigungsminister und da geht es
nicht und beleidigt halten sondern um
die ernsthaftigkeit der aufgabe und die
erfüllt sie herzlichen dank auch dafür
in dieser wichtigen und schwierigen
aufgabe
ich will meinen leuten den bürgern mama
gefragt seid ihr dann zu schnell bei
veränderungen
ich glaube für markus bis zur schwelle
des tempo ist zu viel das tempo der
veränderungen machen nicht wir aber die
geschwindigkeit der reaktion das
entscheiden wir
ich höre immer wieder von den zeitgeist
nicht hinterherlaufen klar wer
hinterherläuft der ist schon lange weg
liebe freunde wir müssen ihn prägen
ich guck mal den satz zu hören wir
müssen der fels in der brandung sein
dann stelle ich die frage wo du stehst
gibt es gar kein wasser mehr
wir können
[Applaus]
wir sind eigentlich eine ganz starke
truppe wenn wir die geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland
so betrachtet wer hat die wirklich
wichtigen weichenstellungen getroffen ob
es soziale marktwirtschaft aber knapp
die anderen waren dagegen wir waren
dafür
es war richtig die frage der
westintegration die anderen waren
dagegen wir waren dafür es war sehr
knapp umstritten es war richtig die
deutsche einheit
jetzt feiern sie alle ja einige sind
skeptisch aber wie war das damals wir
hatten den mut entscheidungen zu treffen
voranzugehen
die anderen waren dagegen und es war
richtig machen wir sagen ja
und immer wenn die herausforderung am
größten war waren wir doch eigentlich am
besten zum lasst uns nicht so klein
möglich sein
lasst uns nicht den ganzen tag immer nur
die kleinen dinge begriffen
lasst uns den ganzen tag verhaken den
formalitäten und ähnlichen sondern lasst
uns schon an einigen stellen einfach mit
offenem herzen und wachen geist
versuchen die probleme zu lösen
ein zurück einfach in die uralte zeitlos
schön war das wäre wirklich wunderbar wo
alles geordnet war das wird es in dieser
welt so schnell nicht geben
und wenn wir das wirklich auch
intellektuell redlich machen dann müssen
wir uns problemen stellen
herausforderungen annehmen und sie dann
auch mit der inneren bereitschaft sie
lösen zu wollen anzugehen die leute
spüren ganz genau ob jemand lust am
regieren hat oder ob es als last
empfindet ich kann nur eines sagen und
es ist mein appell an uns gemeinsam die
menschen möchten uns vertrauen die
menschen wollen eine union die übrigens
auch selbst sich vertraut denn nur wenn
wir uns selber begeistern können
aber wenn man auch die leute begeistern
stellt euch vor ein vertreter kommt an
den türen will ich was verkaufen als das
was er sagt also ich persönlich würde
das nicht kaufen ja die persönlichen die
abschlussquote wird eher dünn sein
also müssen wir auch alle miteinander
und das ist glaube ich wichtig am
sonntag auch botschafter seines willens
und eine bereitschaft das können andere
schon und andere zeigen dass sie mehr
als je zuvor
und da müssen wir eine antwort finden
und unsere antwort muss sein
geschlossenheit stabilität aber auch
offenheit die neuen herausforderungen
anzugehen und jedenfalls was mein
beitragen was unser beitrag ist als csu
zu dieser historischen herausforderungen
in schwieriger zeit zu leisten wollen
wir gehen mit euch gemeinsam wir sind
die stärksten und unser ziel muss sein
ist auch in zukunft zu bleiben
herzlichen dank alles gute viel erfolg
für unsere gemeinschaft wie vanille
dankeschön
ja liebe zu schauen und zuschauer und
sie sehen es heftigen applaus gibt es
von den delegierten für das grußwort des
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten markus
söder der hier noch einmal ganz klar
gesagt hat dass geschlossenheit
stabilität und offenheit neue dinge
anzugehen die schlüsselwörter sind für
den erfolg der union nur gemeinsam ist
man stark das war einer seiner zentralen
botschaften und er hat hier in seiner
rede auch klar gemacht wer der feind aus
seiner sicht der union ist das sei die
afd
diese partei so söder sei alles andere
als eine bürgerliche partei die fdp die
neue hfd
und er hat hier auch klar gemacht wen er
als haupt herausforderer der union sieht
das ist seiner meinung bündnis 90 die
grünen
markus söder lobte ich hier auch das
klima paket der bundesregierung und
sagte ganz klar dass er vor allen dingen
die ihnen doppelmoral vorwerfen würde
bei vielen politischen themen und genau
da kommt es aus seiner sicht auf die
union an verlässlicher partner zu sein
für die bürger und so empfiehlt wer sich
hier sicherlich auch als einer der
staaten redner der union und als
möglicher das ist ja hier immer so ein
bisschen die frage auf diesem parteitag
kanzlerkandidat einer union in der
zukunft das hat er hier natürlich nicht
genannt aber sie sehen was dann doch
schon am applaus und wenn sie genau hin
die für sichter der delegierten direkt
hat man hat hier markus söder genau
gelauscht jetzt gibt es kommt ein paar
worte der vorteil wird es in der union
wir sind die starke mitte in deutschland
nicht mit fragezeichen nicht mehr punkt
sondern mit ausrufezeichen
seine rede hat das heute wieder deutlich
gemacht vielen dank dafür
[Applaus]
ja und hier erfolgte das dankeswort der
parteivorsitzenden der cdu an die
schwesterpartei csu und der klaus hält
noch an und wir wollen mal die
gelegenheit nutzen um nachzufragen wie
denn diese rede hier von markus söder
bei der jungen union angekommen ist da
ist meine kollegin inge swolek und wir
geben zum stand der jungen union ab hier
aus dem saal der delegierten junge union
der stand ist noch leer ich nehme man
alle haben der söder rede gefolgt sie
war gerade dabei gibt haben sie die rede
das war eine sehr prominente rede die
die leute glauben ich richtig
mitgenommen hat man saß an den standing
ovations ist das war eine gute rede die
matratze oder gehalten hat die csu
besser reden als die cdu politik ich
glaube wir können beide kulturen das hat
auf jeden fall spaß gemacht mal wieder
staat jetzt für den sonntag noch mal
welche punkte haben ihn am besten
gefallen ich glaube hat noch mal gut
aufgezeigt wo wir uns halt auch gerade
von den grünen abgrenzen können weil ich
glaube dass wir gerade in diesen zeiten
halt wirklich die grünen als unseren
stärksten konkurrenten wahrnehmen müssen
aber auch entlassen müssen was die
grünen hat gerade nicht eine bürgerliche
politik für alle machen sondern
tatsächlich eine klientel politik machen
und dass die union weiterhin als
volkspartei dann funktioniert wenn ich
cdu und junger union google da kommt er
eigentlich immer
so die grundstimmung ist nicht ganz gut
ohne abstimmung ja oder nein ak gegen
junge union grundrente wirtschaftsflügel
junge union wollen wir kippen oder nicht
warum was stimmt da nicht stimmt die
chemie nicht mehr ganz also ich denke
dass wir jetzt nach 14 jahren angela
merkel die aufgabe haben die partei zu
erneuern und dabei werden wir die
gewählte parteivorsitzende annegret
kramp karrenbauer unterstützen
das ist ein das ist nach 14 jahren
kanzlerschaft merkel und 18 jahren
parteivorsitz keine einfache aufgabe
aber wir verstehen uns natürlich als
innovationsmotor und da ist es unsere
jobbeschreibung sozusagen die cdu auch
ein bisschen zu treiben lassen sie uns
zu dem antrag der ja auf dem
csu-parteitag schon abgeschmettert wurde
abstimmung über den kanzlerkandidaten
der wird ja heute doch verhandelt was
erwarten sie sich davon
ich erwarte mir auf jeden fall dass es
dazu eine debatte geben wird also die
junge union hat den antrag ja mit einer
zweidrittelmehrheit auf ihrem
deutschlandtag in saarbrücken
beschlossen
und ich gehe davon aus dass es hier auf
jeden fall heiß hergehen wird zu diesem
thema wir sagen die basis ist
selbstbewusster geworden ist nicht mehr
wie 2005 als angela merkel als unsere
kanzlerkandidatin aufgestellt wurde
sondern die mitglieder wollen heute mehr
mitreden mehr mitbestimmen und wir
werden für unseren beschluss kämpfen
hier in leipzig aus die cdu soll das
profil schärfen habe ich gelesen auch
ein vorwurf der jungen union wie stellen
sie sich das vor
ich glaube dass wir wieder klare inhalte
stehen müssen wir müssen nachts geweckt
werden und sagen kann ein 23 dafür steht
die jungen oder die union und auch
natürlich junge union ich glaube wir als
junge union sind tatsächlich motor wie
patrick das grab schon gesagt ich glaube
wir haben hier klare anträge zu klaren
positionen die die
generationengerechtigkeit in den
vordergrund stellen und ich hoffe dass
wir die durch bekommen ja vielen dank
junger stimmen es heißt ja auch zeit für
junge köpfe und damit zurück zum michael
kolz herzlichen dank inge und
wachgerüttelt sind die delegierten hier
auf jeden fall
bei mir ist professor karl rudolf korte
normal psychologe an der uni duisburg
essen professor korte ich falle gleich
mal mit der tür ins haus haben wir da
gerade den kanzlerkandidaten gehört das
ist nicht neu
nicht das werden wir in einem jahr sehen
aber er hält sich auch bereit auch werde
das im moment abstreitet die union hat
ja die csu hat ja mit strauß und mit
stoiber zweimal schon einen
kanzlerkandidaten miteingebracht
insofern das ist nicht unwahrscheinlich
dass so hatte sie auch ergeben kann
entscheidend ist ob vor kramp
karrenbauer von ihrem amt ableitet dass
sie vielleicht auch einen rückzug war
eine kandidatur von anderen
vorzuschlagen sie hat es in der hand
zurück zu ziehen vielleicht für einen
tausch einer fraktionsvorsitz oder sie
hat es zuzulassen dass ein anderer
kandidat gefunden wird oder sie tritt
selbst an es liegt an ihr
man kann im moment nicht ableiten wie
dieser prozess am ende aussieht weil er
auch davon abhängt wer vielleicht am
ende der interessante koalitionspartner
sein könnte interessant ist aber in all
den jahren des parteivorsitzes durch
angela merkel waren die sticheleien aus
münchen groß intensiv und da hat die
union also hier die cdu immer eine
eigene schutz haltung eingenommen wird
gesagt die kleine csu ihr bleibt da wo
ihr seid jetzt haben wir die reaktion
gerade im saal gesät das klingt ja quasi
das ist ja paradox das ist jetzt
plötzlich genau andersrum ist hat markus
söder die rede gehalten die viele der
delegierten von ihrer vorsitzenden gern
gehört nein es nicht vergleichbar denn
die frau kam kam bauer hat einfach die
auseinandersetzung die 30 mitarbeiter
auf der bühne zu sehen ist mit einer
parteivorsitzenden als parteivorsitzende
mit der kanzlerin
das ist ja bei söder eine ganz andere
konstellation ist sie hätte nie die
gleiche rede halten von aber so
humorvoll auch so als politisches
kabarett etwas zu halten er hat ein
bisschen am nockherberg entschuldigt
dass ich unterbreche kann man nur wenn
man sehr machtpolitisch gefestigt ist
das ist er jetzt so hat er auch
innerliche wendungen gemacht in bayern
er hat auch zugegeben was er im
wahlkampf falsch gemacht hat versucht
hat die iaaf die rechts zu überholen in
vielen punkten
das war ein eingeständnis aber vor allen
dingen wenn man davon ausgeht dass er
mit seehofer viele jahre einen ringen
hat wann der partei auf ihn zukommen
kann man erkennen was am ende daraus
geworden ist seehofer ist der
parteivorsitzende der am häufigsten
nicht zurückgetreten ist in all den
jahren
und das hat auch gezehrt natürlich an
söder jetzt ist sehr gefestigt und kann
ausgesagt machtposition auch eine
relativ lockere rede hatten im vorkampf
kamera ist keinesfalls gleichermaßen so
gefestigt dass sie hier eine rein
humorvolle rede halten bzw
das hatte ja schon was von wahlkampf ist
gefährlich wenn markus söder die spd
jetzt einfach mal in den papierkorb
schiebt als konkurrenz nein er hat ja
auch teile gelobt wie gering die
finanzminister aber ja es klingt ein
bisschen mitleidig das als partner
scheint die spd ihm sogar lieber zu sein
als die grünen mit denen er sich doch
sehr auseinander gesetzt hat und ihn
doppelmoral vorgeworfen er hat praktisch
viele argumente geliefert für die
delegierten wie sie am wahlkampfstand
mit anderen parteien und mit um mit
umfragen und auch mit anderen argumenten
sich positiv auseinandersetzen können
das war nicht hilfreich für denke ich
die delegierten am ende wenn sie damit
nach hause fahren nach all den jahren wo
es schwieriger war zwischen cdu/csu
müssen wir noch ein satz über die
gemeinsamkeit verlieren
wie eng stehen die schwestern momentan
zusammen offensichtliches markus söder
und an der gag am karl bauer ja gelungen
zumindest einigkeit zu demonstrieren ist
das fakt oder eher eine illusion
nein das ist fakt also zwischen merkel
und seehofer lief gar nichts mehr
und mit neuem personal gibt es immer
möglichkeiten auch probleme die bestehen
bleiben und dass viele sichtweisen über
ein neues personal in neuer kooperation
auszugleichen dass es überall zu spüren
hier auf dem parteitag auch es gibt
nicht mehr ein bisschen diese
feindschaft die man mal ausgesprochen
wurde zur csu sondern es ist ein schon
eine gemeinsamkeit die sich wieder
gefestigter denn der haupt
auseinandersetzung war ja die migrations
thematik durch stets thematik dort hat
vor allem die bayerische csu dazugelernt
im wahlkampf dass ihr harter kurs nicht
benotet bei den bürgerlichen mitte
wählen und ich glaube das war der
entscheidende punkt dass die annäherung
an die cdu auch wird er möglich wurde
ein satz zu seiner vermeintlichen
vorliebe für den koalitionspartner spd
rein rechnerisch ist es ja inzwischen
gar nicht mehr möglich das heißt noch
mal ist es nicht ein bisschen gefährlich
dann sozusagen die grünen in die linke
ecke zu schieben wenn es doch relativ
wahrscheinlich sein könnte dass nach der
nächsten bundestagswahl
das der einzig möglichen
koalitionspartner wäre aber er greift es
ja nicht diffamierend an
er spaltet nicht sondern er setzt sich
auf eine intellektuelle weise durchaus
auch humorvoll mit wettbewerber
auseinander ich glaube das ist wichtig
auch für am ende wäre nur weder zu
wissen wo der unterschied sein könnte
das schließt ja eine partnerschaft in
koalition nicht grundsätzlich aus es ist
sicherlich ein bayerischer blick er
hätte ja auch die möglichkeit mit den
grünen zusammenzuarbeiten er hat jetzt
bevorzugt mit den freien wählern eine
koalition zu bilden eine kleinere
mehrheit als große zu organisieren
insofern ist es auch ein bayerischer
blick aber er schließt ja damit nicht
grundsätzlich ein zusammen aber aus
zumal die grünen ja mit allen parteien
oder mit vielen parteien koalitionen
gebildet habe eben auch mit der cdu
ich sage herzlichen dank für karl rudolf
korte für die analysen hier beim
cdu-bundesparteitag